all right guys
bang bang i have a awesome treat for you
today amanda is here and we're going to
talk about everything that she does on a
daily basis so thank you so much for
coming on and doing this
thank you so much for having me i'm
delighted to be here
absolutely uh let's jump right in uh
let's go over your background first
before we get to the fun stuff maybe
just tell us kind of
where did you grow up and what did you
do before you got to uh pnc
i am originally from the scranton
pennsylvania area and the poconos if
you're familiar with that
but i moved around a bunch as a kid as
my dad got transferred
through a number of jobs so i spent time
in pennsylvania obviously where i was
born i spent a number of years in
alabama
i lived in indiana and then kind of
finally made my way back to
pennsylvania i live in the city of
philadelphia here
with my husband and two girls they're
eight and four
um the door behind me is locked to try
and keep the four-year-old from banging
on the door and trying to
to make her grand debut here i went to
penn state
so go state i'm definitely a nittany
lion
through and through my career has
largely been a long and winding road
through
the asset management business and the
investment management industry so
right out of college i spent a number of
years working in
investment banking i was a private
equity analyst for a little while which
was kind of interesting to see
what's going on in the private market
world the lion share my career believe
it or not has been spent in equity
research
as a generalist covering covering a
number of
sectors and industries and i think that
really was sort of the best training
ground for where i find myself
today as a strategist it's really given
me kind of a broad
view of the world and kind of the inner
workings of the markets
um and so i think that helps from a
practitioner's standpoint
i definitely do not come to this job
from an academic standpoint it's really
more learning on the job and effectively
kind of being street smart if you will
so a long and winding road through the
industry and i think that gives me kind
of an interesting and perhaps
differentiated view of the world
absolutely and so today you sit as the
chief
investment strategist at pnc bank
uh as we were talking beforehand there's
a whole bunch of stuff that goes on
at pnc so help us understand kind of
what that
role entails and then kind of where you
sit within the organization
so as the chief investment strategist
for pnc
i lead the team that's responsible for
developing all the strategic
and tactical asset allocation
recommendations
for our clients in the asset management
division
and our client base really spans three
primary lines of business we have
institutional clients so endowments
foundations pension plans of
all different sizes we have an
individual
kind of wealth oriented private client
business and then we have an ultra high
net worth family office business
called hawthorne and so my purview is
really to drive the asset allocation
both strategic and tactical for all
three lines of business as well as
kind of uh publish on a fairly high
frequency
trying to make sense of the insanity
that is this market and so we put
information out on a weekly monthly
quarterly basis and then
ad hoc depending on whatever is going on
so
we really own an investment strategy
kind of the house views
of the markets and the investment
landscape across
both public equities private uh
investments
and fixed income okay so
uh this is a big important job is the uh
is the takeaway for the
people who don't understand the finance
road who are listening to this this is
really important because
asset allocation is one of the most
important decisions that people
are going to end up making maybe talk a
little bit from your perspective
the importance of asset allocation
versus actual manager selection
or kind of individual security selection
and kind of how you
think almost like top down from that
asset allocation to
the rest of the portfolio construction
that goes on
well the asset allocation decision is a
really really
important part of the portfolio
management process
and the investment management kind of
approach it's not the only decision but
is definitely a critical
first step and but really in order to do
a good job of deciding what the right
asset allocation
should be we really need to get a clear
understanding of a client's goals and
objectives and so
we're very goals based and goals
oriented and can we quantify that goal
or objective as a starting point
and then decide what is the appropriate
asset allocation recommendation
to build around it to actually be able
to support that
you know you could have the greatest
ideas in the world
but if you're not even close to being in
the right ballpark in terms of the
potential to generate
the returns that a client might need to
support their longer term goals and
objectives
it's still kind of a failure and so at
the end of the day we really do start by
trying to identify
and then more importantly quantify that
goal or objective
and then the asset allocation decision
comes in a close second
that really is the guiding light for how
we build portfolios
but we work in very very close
partnership with our
partners in manager research so those
that are doing due diligence on
third party strategies that we might
implement so
a core fixed income manager or a venture
capital strategy
or even just an s p 500 growth oriented
strategy
and we also work very closely with the
portfolio construction team to make sure
that
when we put the asset allocation and the
manager
recommendations together that we don't
end up with unintended
exposures or consequences again you
could have the greatest asset allocation
in the world and the greatest set of
managers but you could end up with
really outsized exposures and things you
are not looking for when you start
putting a multi-asset class portfolio
together so the portfolio construction
piece of it
is really important i really think all
three components are actually
very very important but if you don't get
the client into the right
ballpark you know right out of the gate
from an asset allocation perspective
it can be a very tough client experience
can you talk a little bit about the
process you go through in terms of
getting to kind of the asset allocation
recommendation
or directive like what is that process
both from kind of
internalizing and synthesizing all the
information that's out there
and then actually putting that into kind
of a final directive as to here's the
asset allocation
we're going to move forward for clients
well it's usually as simple as
developing an investment policy
statement
that's kind of a standard starting point
both from cfa institute so industry
standard uh
kind of guidance and recommendations and
also what we would do
at pnc and through the investment
strategy
starting point and so when you're
looking at an investment policy
statement
you're trying to understand what are the
key components
or values that we need to try to express
in a portfolio context and then we're
holding ourselves accountable to that so
it's a document that
we develop but the client also buys into
and so it's really important from a
setting expectations
upfront kind of approach so we all agree
that this is the approach that we're
going to take and then
to the extent that it deviates or our
clients goals and objectives change we
would update guidance as it relates to
that investment policy statement and so
when you think about the components of
it it's return objectives
it's risk tolerance it's special or
unique consideration so in the case of
an individual or an ultra high net worth
family office type of relationship
sometimes there are big slugs a very low
if not
zero cost basis stock in part of the
portfolio and so
how do they want to address that how do
they want to handle that and how should
we be building a portfolio around that
we want to make sure that we have a very
holistic view and picture
so that we can make sure that we're
choosing the right
recommendation or asset allocation
positioning
time horizon is another important one so
if i only have five years
to get a client to its goals and
objectives very very different
recommendation than if i have 30 figures
in the case of a foundation which
usually tends to be
our most aggressive asset allocation
positioning
we have a very different set of
recommendations both whether
clients want to use public equities and
public fixed income or they want to
consider
using alternatives so there's a lot of
different flavors
and a lot of different direction that we
can take with it we try to be
you know really goals based and highly
customized
and so this is definitely not a
one-size-fits-all approach
um a lot of leg work up front but then
at the end of the day we feel like that
is really
valuable conversation um in making sure
that you know we can achieve success for
the clients over the long term
got it and so i'm gonna assume that uh
it was
relatively business as usual until uh
the beginning of this year call it
sometime between january and march
uh and then all hell broke loose
basically in markets right and
everything from
uh kind of credit markets seizing up to
public equities
dropping and then exploding up in value
you saw commodities kind of all over the
place
um maybe talk a little bit just in with
the hindsight benefit now
of like where we sit today in uh
september of 2020
what's transpired from your position
up until now and then we can talk about
kind of moving forward but these are
some of the craziest markets that many
people have kind of
navigated and so kind of how have you
navigated those markets and kind of
what's changed from an asset allocation
standpoint for the clients that you guys
serve
so there's so much in that uh question
we could spend the entire time together
talking about that one let me start and
then you guide me
uh where you want me to go from there so
in thinking about
kind of into the end of 2019 and rolling
the calendar forward to 2020
we're actually feeling pretty good
despite how far the market had moved in
the back half of last year we were
feeling pretty good about positioning
we were starting to see some green
shoots in terms of a cyclical
acceleration
after a really kind of slow and tough if
not choppy slog over the course of 2019
and
well i'll just throw this out for fun
like every year
i try to assign um a musical reference
or a song of the year
for the coming year and so this is going
to sound insane now looking back on it
but it's there's still
some truth to it the song we picked for
this year
um was the grateful dead trucking
and so the idea really was that given
all of what has gone on the long strange
trip that was the prior business cycle
investors really shouldn't get tripped
up um by some of the challenges that
were in front of us that we thought this
like the cycle still had legs and
it could keep going and so we did start
to see in january and february
pre-covered
that meaningful acceleration start to
take hold so we were feeling pretty good
about positioning and didn't make a ton
of changes
early in the year we did over the last
like 18 months like leading up to that
start to make some changes at the margin
because we felt like the cycle was
getting pretty long in the tooth
and we thought the volatility was going
to continue to pick up
were there a lot of headline risks macro
challenges around trade policy and that
sort of thing and so
to try and get clients still comfortable
with being fully invested
not overweight but comfortably fully
invested
according to their investment policy
statements and their strategic asset
allocation
we started to incorporate some asset
classes that had a little bit more
ballast
in them so as a good example we
incorporated global infrastructure
and that's a nice way to kind of
straddle the u.s and international
markets
stay in equities but dial back some of
the volatility exposure and so that was
kind of a key
story for 2019 even though the market
finally got it back together towards the
end of the year
of course covet hit that was not in our
crystal ball
sadly it was not in our 2020 outlook
by any means and so the world shifted
uh pretty dramatically um the the good
news or bad news about it is
i think there were only about three days
in the midst of the record-breaking
downdraft
and then rally that anybody really had a
shot at repositioning portfolios in a
significant way and so believe it or not
we stayed fully invested and rode
right through it um even though
volatility as measured by the vix
hit you know 80 plus like all-time
records and so our view on it was
really one that the markets
over time have wrestled with pandemics
this is not a new phenomenon
you know dealing with pandemics though
the magnitude of this one has obviously
been
really significant what was new is that
we proactively or
maybe reactively depending on how you
want to look at it shut down the global
economy
those two things were never synced up
before and so that was really
the key difference this wasn't um an
asset bubble bursting
or the kind of a typical or usual end to
a cycle
we shut this thing down and so
in our view we didn't think that there
was a need to really pull the record and
de-risk
you know we've seen these things sadly
play out before you know the financial
crisis is a good training ground for
how big markets can whipsaw
around events like this and so we felt
given the strength
coming into 2020 the fact that this was
artificially induced that as we shut
down the global economy in response to
it
that it would be kind of a bridging the
gap shorter term
type of event and that you know maybe
things wouldn't normalize overnight but
that we would start to get
back to a recovery and relatively
shorter and so we felt
good about kind of staying the course of
course what has changed
since then is uh it wasn't just a few
short weeks you know it's hard to
believe that we're still
all very much kind of working remotely
and
i think something like half of uh gdp
tied to states today is still
in some form of pausing um or
readjusting the reopening plan so we're
definitely not
back to normal and i would say we're
definitely not that good new
normal but some lessons that we have
learned
really so far in the short period of
time is that
um there's a real distinction between
the haves and have-nots wall street
versus main street so
we we've started to see an even bigger
way than
pre-covid this really bifurcated market
and economic environment
start to assert itself here and you can
see it
in the day-to-day movement in the public
equity markets depending on what the
news flow
is suggesting on any given day it's the
stay-at-home trade you know everything
you need when you're hunkered down
or it's the go outside trade and it's
just this churning that continues to go
on
but net net we think a really
significant perhaps structural
difference as a function
of what has gone on since cove began
is really that the bigger likely to get
bigger and that the growthy are likely
to get growthier
and so what does that mean it means that
you know regardless of how long
this environment persists we think that
the bigger
names the mega cap tech in particular so
the queues which have garnered a ton
of headlines lately are really likely to
use this
environment to their advantage you can
already see it
in the companies that have fortress-like
balance sheets
that are paying dividends that have the
potential to grow their dividends
you can see it in the m a market um
there's leverage that's occurring here
for those business models that have been
able to kind of manage
fairly swimmingly technical terms
swimmingly through this
environment and yet the value side of
the equation
continues to struggle in a meaningful
way and so our view
over the course of the summer shifted to
be wait a minute this is not just a very
short-term
phenomenon we think there's something to
this and so we did tactically shift
away from small and mid-cap value
in domestic markets specifically because
of that and when we think about
small and mid value we're really looking
at exposures that span
the energy sector the financial sector
reits and even parts of consumer
discretionary and
we can talk about all the kind of thesis
and rationale behind that but even where
we sit
today even how far the market has
rallied
it's really hard to point to a
significant positive catalyst
to really get any of those sectors and
especially the
ones that are sitting in the smaller cap
part of the spectrum
going again we think that all the
stimulus that has come into the system
has definitely saved the day
chair powell with a superhero cape on
absolutely changed the game
critical um but it also has
mass at least on the fiscal side it is
also mass a lot of the underlying
stresses
um that are only now starting to kind of
show up in the system and so
we've seen a few bankruptcies we've seen
some defaults but we really haven't seen
a meaningful default cycle
start up yet i think the longer this
goes on
and the longer we are not able to get
some form of fiscal stimulus going
the tougher slog is going to be so we
may need to do more there
from a positioning standpoint but
believe it or not we are very
comfortable with our exposure
in the nasdaq 100 right now it's not let
me just clarify that is not our only
exposure but making that
tactical shift there even where
valuations are sitting and even how far
um that part of the market has rallied
we think there's a lot of opportunity
left
there you literally couldn't have played
it any better in hindsight
in terms of how you guys have navigated
this i think one of the
kind of big you know turning points if
you will
of what's transpired over the last six
or seven months has been the
intervention of the fed and so obviously
we had that kind of two emergency rate
cuts right that brought us to a zero
rate environment
uh there's now guidance that will stay
at that zero rate environment for
the foreseeable future uh we've had kind
of three plus trillion dollars
from a quantitative easing standpoint uh
there's a lot of people calling for more
maybe it comes maybe it doesn't
talk just a little bit about kind of the
fed's role in all of this and really
from the light
of uh i think kind of maybe you know
back in
march april and maybe into may the
debate was like is it
a uh a v recovery a w recovery like
there's a couple of these letters that
were thrown out there
now there's a new letter that's being
thrown out which is this kind of k
recovery which is what you're talking
about of like asset owners
are seeing a major recovery and there's
this great kind of story around
investment
going up at the same time kind of
economic data may be going down
those who don't have investment assets
kind of suffering so how do you just see
kind of the federal reserve their role
and kind of how that may have caused
this like you know
bifurcated response from the market
another doozy of a question absolutely
so let me start by saying
we're not going necessarily with a
k-shaped
recovery although to your point there
definitely is a distinction between the
companies that will survive
and move ahead get a leg up um on their
peers and their competition and others
that will just
cease to exist so i guess from that
perspective and just the existence of
businesses i will give you that
shape of recovery we actually get this
question all the time
you know what letter of the alphabet are
we talking about from a market
recovery standpoint and i always joke
and say
d none of the above that we go
with a square root shape symbol the mass
symbol square
root shape and this is uh the shape of
the recovery that we actually
coined back in i think it was april um
and the thought was really that
of course we had seen that
record-breaking collapse in the market
those three short days uh with you know
a flurry of activity and then this
again record-breaking rally to near if
not
all-time highs where we find ourselves
today
is really in that long horizontal bar
in terms of the square root shape and i
think that's very much indicative from a
market
from a 30 000 foot level where we think
we're likely to be
at least through the election if not
through the end of the year you know
this market has really rallied to a
place
where at least in terms of the s p 500
it's pricing for perfection
so forward p e on the s p 500 is
somewhere in the neighborhood of 22
times
well above longer term averages and yet
the backdrop
is anything but perfect it's one of the
most challenging
backdrops certainly in my career perhaps
in my lifetime and many others and so
there is this
significant disconnect between where the
market is sitting
today and what the catalysts are to keep
this rally going now this is where the
fed
comes into play in a huge way because
for as much as i'm saying
i'm struggling to find a positive
catalyst to keep this rally going
i'm also struggling to find meaningful
negative catalysts
where the bottom is literally going to
drop out of this
market environment we just don't see it
we really see this as being much more
of a range bound kind of choppy elevated
volatility
backdrop for a while until one of two
things
kind of breaks and one is the election
and the outcome of the election
whatever may happen with that we can
certainly talk about that
but the other actually bigger catalyst
in our view is what happens with covid
um
and so again we can talk about that a
little bit more but without the fed's
intervention
taking policy rates to zero and
basically being the 7 trillion
backstop right the buyer of last resort
very very active through a number of
programs across
most if not all fixed income asset
classes
we would be in a very different place
today so
they changed the game in terms of
liquidity so we
basically when we shut down the global
economy we went into a liquidity drought
everything froze up in the system and
that was really
the catalyst for it um it wasn't that
you know banks were over
levered or any of that sort of thing
just the pipes froze up
and so the fed changed the game in terms
of
fixing the plumbing and getting things
working again the challenge is that they
can only do so much
so they cannot solve these solvency
issues
that are still lingering around and
that's where the fiscal stimulus story
needs to come in
with the fed's massive intervention
and wildly accommodate a policy it has
done
wonders to calm fixed income markets
so for as much as i'm saying well we got
a lot of volatility on the equity side
of the equation
and it's going to get bumpier if you
look at the vix uh
the the fear gauge or the volatility
index
um it's pretty elevated into the end of
this year if you're looking at the
futures curve for the vix
um and you might say oh well it's just a
function of the election no big deal but
this year actually the vix is much more
elevated
than even in the last two election
cycles
and so we really do think that it is
reflective of
the heightened degree of uncertainty
ahead not only with the outcome of the
election
but whether we'll know what the outcome
is on election night and then certainly
covet in a series of
other things there so while the equity
market is
really bumpy and chopping around
it's a sense of calm in fixed income
markets we're seeing volatility there
basically near all-time lows so the fed
has really solved things on the fixed
income side from a volatility standpoint
what we're finding is much more
challenging now is really price
discovery
and distinguishing between kind of
winners and losers
because there's this unlimited backstop
and so again fed changed the game
superhero cape
in in share pal what they did in a
matter of a week
it took the bernanke fed six months or
more to do
um during and post the financial crisis
so
totally swooped in there but it has had
really important implications for
the path forward for fixed income
investors so
you know what are you going to do in a
zero rate environment where are you
going to pick up returns
and then like the closer you are to the
zero bound
in terms of policy rates just inherently
see more volatility in the interest rate
backdrop and so we're entering this
weird paradigm
weird again technological term we're
entering this weird paradigm
where fixed income positioning isn't
going to do much for you
in a growth starved and yield starved
world you're not expecting to see
a lot of meaningful returns out of fixed
income going forward
not expecting to see a lot of yield
either and a fixed income
which should be the safe haven or the
ballast in the portfolio
starts experiencing some outside
volatility
it's it's a real pickle uh for for
investors
and so we're watching kind of how things
play out there
very very carefully and really are
kind of rethinking although we haven't
made any major changes yet
we are kind of rethinking positioning
there really in response to what the fed
has done
the fed talks a lot about you know
trying to get
inflation up if not above that two
percent long-term target so they really
want
inflation to run hot but if you look at
the bond markets
they're just not signaling or flashing
signs of yields getting ready to repair
nor inflation ripping higher either here
and then even when you look at fed funds
futures
so out to say like january of 2022
the market is still effectively pricing
some downward pressure
it's really sitting at zero out that far
and
at on any given day you could see rates
kind of trading into negative territory
so the fed may want rates to move
higher from here longer term uh not in
the very short run
but the market is definitely looking in
a very different direction
so yeah we'll see how to reconcile that
as we go through the next
few quarters and years i could literally
talk to you all day because you already
know the questions i'm gonna ask
which are uh in a zero rate environment
there's been a ton of people who have
come on the podcast and talked about
you know 60 40 global portfolios are
dead because you've got so much exposure
to kind of
a zero rate or close to it a lot of kind
of
negative real rate type return profiles
and different asset classes
talk maybe just a little bit like one is
that an overhyped kind of narrative
around the 60 40
not being kind of the gold standard
anymore and will that change
and then two you started to talk a
little bit about inflation but part of
this kind of zero rate environment is
really trying to drive that inflation up
uh and really is it possible for them to
get up above two percent for any kind of
persistent amount of time
well you know as the strategist this
whole
60 40 debate is so frustrating let me
tell you
because like the best game in town
literally has been
the s p 500 and the barclays act split
60
40. so so i am all in on the frustration
on the part of you know the broader
investment community
of the challenges around this you know i
i'm the first one to admit that
diversification though it may be
a very well thought out thesis has not
actually
ruled the day for the lion's share of
the past cycle and
certainly for periods of what we've
experienced this year
i think at the end of the day you kind
of have to look at it from a
multi-pronged approach so
the asset allocation story can only get
you so far
right if you have unreasonable
expectations
in terms of return targets and
objectives
60 40 isn't going to cut it even in an
ideal or perfect
market environment which is absolutely
not where we are today
um we've had a 40-year bull market
effectively in fixed income
and in bonds right so we are absolutely
at an
inflection point and so i think that
really
does require us to rethink what kind of
that's
a standard kind of balanced asset
allocation
really should be like going forward at
the same time
i struggle with saying well 80 20 is the
answer
or even 90 10 or 100 equities
given where evaluations are sitting so
it's a very very challenging time
for investors and especially those that
like on the institutional side in
particular we find this very very
challenging because they're trying to
support operating budgets
there's regulatory requirements to spend
at a certain level you know private
foundations have to spend
five when you layer on inflation and
an assumption for fees you're at seven
and a half just to barely break even
on an expected return basis and so
it is a very very challenging backdrop
but we do wrestle with this idea of well
let's ratchet up the equity exposure as
an offset and so
um try a part of what we're kind of
working through now is thinking about
other more creative ways to perhaps step
back from fixed income and
consider hedge fund strategies that may
have more defensive characteristics or
private market
investments that again can throw off
some yield and some cash
but are not kind of subject to the whims
of public equity
market and pricing volatility to try and
gain some of that balance back and so
uh there is no silver bullet uh by any
means the other piece of it that can be
helpful at times is thinking about the
mix of active and passive
strategies in portfolios so if all you
do is own an etf
in fixed income you have no shot at
beating
the benchmark that you're attached to
but if you think about
you know active managers that can
provide careful
credit analysis and deviate from from
the benchmark be very nimble
in terms of their exposures be
thoughtful about the sectors and
industries
so not backing up the truck in energy
cpe
read the federal we talked about earlier
that is another way to potentially add
value in a very low return environment
so you really have to come at it from a
bunch of different
angles and at the end of the day set
expectations up front because
clients can be like oh yeah i want that
seven and a half percent return but they
may not be able to sleep at night with
the bouncing around
that that portfolio might take so i hear
you
i'm all in on it it's very frustrating i
don't think that that
that is necessarily the right starting
point
just given all these other factors but
i'm not really ready to throw it out
either yeah the answer is kind of it
depends
on your line of sight and really what
you're trying to achieve
that is a a completely fair answer i
think
um i want to talk about a couple of more
things
uh let's start first with uh the
election
i think that um everyone is looking
at november and saying uh this has many
implications
uh for this conversation let's just
focus on the
financial markets and kind of what can
happen there
there will be plenty of people who want
to debate tax implications and kind of
social implications all that we'll leave
that for another conversation
but from a financial market standpoint
um
one just historical context wise do you
guys
put any weight into uh there's plenty of
studies that come out and show kind of
the 90 days leading into an election up
or down kind of tells you who's going to
win
uh and then two how do you look at this
election in terms of
um if either candidate ends up being the
winner like what do you almost
anticipate happening in those markets
so yes we've spent a ton of time looking
at this that's probably
the most important topic
an outcome an event on all of our
clients minds whether they're
institutions or
individuals i would just say let me
start with some general comments
markets hate uncertainty no surprise
there
and so historically speaking markets
tend to prefer
kind of the certainty from outcomes that
are allegedly pro-growth
or at least pro-business-oriented or as
an alternative markets prefer gridlock
because it's really the checks and
balances
that come with a divided government that
tend to prevent more extreme
and uncertain outcomes and that really
is where we get into
a place where the market has trouble
assigning value
so back at the beginning of the year
when there was concern
around bernie sanders or elizabeth
warren potentially getting
the nom for the dems that was a really
concerning potential outcome because you
had a very very strict extreme
kind of far left ideological view there
and we think between that and the
current administration gosh the market
was really going to wrestle with
uh how the outcome was going to impact
things it's all one way or all the other
there was really
not not likely to be much of a middle
ground
with biden getting the nomination and
then pamela harris getting
the vp nomination this is a much more
moderate approach
and so even when you think about the day
that
pamela harris uh got the nomination uh
the market kind of smooths uh another
technical term right the the market
yawned
it was almost in a relevant news
headline that day and i think that's
really kind of where
the market is feeling uh about kind of
the election at this point
it's not so much about biotin or harris
it's really what happens to the overall
makeup
so who's in the white house but who's in
control of the house
and the senate and so that's really
where we have our eye
on the potential for the path forward
it's really the dem
sweep scenario that we think the market
will likely
struggle with um and there's important
implications
there uh for the path forward if that
were to occur
in terms of guideposts you're totally
right there are a lot of different
things that
can be looked at to try and gauge
or game you know how the outcome of the
election may play out
polling data has been notoriously bad
that's gotten a lot of press and a lot
of discussion
so that's not something that we focus on
as a key guide post but it's something
to be mindful of so it's kind of
scrolling around
um in the backdrop there we do look at
betting odds
so according to predicted.org that's a
key source
for us in terms of looking at the
betting odds um
they're giving biden about a 60 odds
of winning the white house and the dems
about a 58
chance of winning the senate the blue
wave or blue sweep kind of scenario is
sitting at about 55
if you think about comparable numbers
back in february
it was much lower so 43 odds for biden
winning
30 for the dems winning the senate and
the sweep i think was down in the
neighbor of 20 or 25 something like that
so
big shift in terms of expectation
um in the betting odds i think my caveat
to that would be it's kind of surprising
that it's not even more significant
just given all of what has transpired
since february but if you just looked at
the betting odds
that would be signaling a change in
control in the white house around the
election
the other thing that we look at very
carefully is actually economic
data and in particular q2 gdp
real disposable income per capita and
even monthly payrolls
have all been really important guides or
predictors
for what may happen in an election year
i think the key question for us
is will voters actually hold trump
responsible
for the disaster those basically all of
these economic indicators and metrics or
are they going to blame
kovid or other forces for this
and kind of give him a pass but if you
just look
purely at the economic data here
just at face value this would also
suggest a change in control so kind of
very unusual and we'll see kind of how
this starts to play out as we move
closer to the election of course the
market though
is also a predictor so again you got to
look at this from a bunch of different
angles context and narrative
really do matter and so usually when
we're looking at the market
and what the market is uh foreseeing
it's really the three months leading up
to the election
and if the market is up the party in
power stays in power
the market is down likely a change in
control it really was the only
indicator that got the 2016 election
correct
and i think that's really interesting
and notable some people forget that
that uh you know it was assumed that
hillary was going to be a landslide well
the market was not suggesting that
the market was down and really the
market had it correct
so from uh august 3rd or so forward if
we're assuming november 3rd is
election day the market is down
and so the market indeed is another guy
post that is suggesting a change in
control now i don't want to go on record
of saying this is definitely how it's
going to play out
but it's a very interesting election
cycle where
all of these guideposts are telling a
similar story and it's changed very
rapidly
just in the last few months if we had
talked
uh in july the market would have been
telling a very very different story
so it we're going to have to watch it
very very closely to see how this
unfolds it's definitely going to be a
race to the finish
yeah what's really interesting about
this is this is probably one of the only
events where
uh we're gonna go to sleep one night and
then we go to sleep the next night
something changed you know in terms of
we got a piece of data that
uh can have such um kind of diverse
outcomes right in terms of
uh covid was there's maybe a week or two
weeks where it got really serious but
again it was still over a two-week
period it wasn't just like one day
kovit's not here
next day covid's here right and kind of
that that type of
very sharp um market reaction
yeah and i think here that definitely
happens on an election and so from an
asset allocation standpoint
do you basically go into the election
almost with like
uh i'll call it like a trump presidency
plan and a biden
uh presidency plan and then depending on
who wins the election
you know the directive can change based
on who that that presidential
uh candidate ends up being or do you go
into it more
with uh maybe a range and you say you
know if it's a landslide then we're
going to be on the most extreme end of
this if it's not
uh maybe we have kind of a more moderate
uh change to asset allocation like how
do you just think about that going into
such a binary event like this
so it's a great question and our clients
have been asking this a lot lately no
surprise
and my answer is we never want to make
grand or sweeping portfolio changes
around a binary event because it's so
easy
and the odds are very high that you're
going to be on the wrong side of that
outcome and so our best advice is really
to maintain a well-diversified portfolio
into through around uh binary
events but take stock of what the
exposures are
in your portfolio be mindful of
positioning
and if there's something that you're
really concerned about and i can talk
about
some of those things then it may be
worth making adjustments but we're never
going to be all
one portfolio or all one another
depending on
the administration that is an important
component
to the path forward for the markets but
it's not the only component and i would
just say
at the end of the day really because
kovid is still
very much alive and well here it has not
faded into the backdrop
even though the data has started to look
better over the course of the summer
we're now starting to see a resurgence
in western europe and there is the
potential
for the covid curves to start hooking
higher here
in a more sustained way in the u.s and
so at the end of the day we actually
think
that is much more critical to the pace
and timing of policy changes coming out
of washington
than just the election itself that is
it's a bit of a mixed blessing
i don't know if that's kind of a crazy
thing to say when you're in a pandemic
but
it will slow down grand and sweeping
policy changes so if we have a change in
control
that new administration and whoever is
controlling congress
is still going to have their hands full
trying to figure out this covid story
not likely to start slapping you know
big tax increases in
right out of the gate in the new year
and so we may ultimately get them
right but it's a little bit of a slower
longer drawn out process in our view
and so i think that will help to calm
equity markets in particular but just
public markets in general
if we were to get a change in control
some of the things that we're thinking
about though
um i can talk through so the the biggie
if trump were to stay in control
and get reelected is what happens on the
trade policy front
if you think back to 2018 and even 2019
every time he put out a tweet
talking about trade policy or
a change in tariffs or an escalation
whether it be china mexico our trading
partners in europe and so on
the market freaked out and yes that is a
technical term
i mean the market just hated
the stance that he was taking around
trade policy
for better or worse that has faded
largely
into the backdrop so we got a handshake
agreement if you will
uh pre-covered at the end of 2019 that
was a very welcome
you know sigh of relief um that that
effectively was now in the rear view
mirror and the market could chart a path
higher
but we're starting to see that rhetoric
pick up again and so to the extent that
he
gets reelected we think that will be a
key focal point
and he will take a much harder line
stance and i think that will
be something that the market is going to
have to wrestle with
for a while yet we might see more
tariffs we might see more
blocking of deals i mean the list could
go on and on depending on
what he decides to do but that will
inject a pretty significant amount of
uncertainty
and i don't think it's really getting
the attention
that it deserves in the media in the
press and really in the markets that's
that's a real
significant headwind and i would say
from a
portfolio positioning standpoint it
would be a big negative for emerging
markets
we do have exposure to emerging markets
we continue to like emerging markets we
think it's one of the most
if not most attractive equity asset
classes across the globe
um they've handled covid uh on a
relatively better basis
i'm not talking china necessarily just
all of emerging markets has done a
collectively better job so they've
entered it and exited first
they've seen a second wave it's been
very mild they've been able to control
it
earnings growth has held up much better
than every other part of the world and
we're seeing
actually a really significant
acceleration projected
for earnings growth in 2021 so fell
a lot less far and a much more
significant acceleration and then the
valuation story for emerging markets
is really attractive it's not quite half
of what the s p
500 is trading at but a very significant
discount
and so for all those reasons we're
actually very comfortable with emerging
market positioning
but to the extent that that trade story
started to rear its ugly head again
it could be a very significant headwind
for our emerging market allocations on
the democrat
side the biggie is taxes and at the end
of the day that is the thing that we're
most concerned about
with a biden win and a dem sweep in
particular
we've done some back in the envelope
calculations based on what he has
proposed so
far corporate rates going back to 28
from the 21 that they are at right now
we think that could knock off somewhere
in the neighborhood of 11 or 12
of earnings growth in 2021 so when you
think about the next 12 months earnings
growth
we're only looking at about one or two
percent the lion's share of the pickup
and acceleration and earnings growth
is in the second half of 2021 it's kind
of a hail mary
into the end of the year and so if he
were to
institute tax increases of this
magnitude very early in the year
boy that is a big headwind for earnings
growth that
is next to none right at one or two
percent and so
as goes the path of earnings so goes the
markets that's a mantra that we say over
and over again and so
um it's not our base case again because
we think the covid story
will trump pun intended the the tax hike
story there
but it is something that we're watching
very closely a small offset to that
could be
biden's softer stance around trade
policy with china
he has kicked around the idea of rolling
back china tariffs
and so if that were to occur that might
get us back
another five or six percent but it's
still a significant net negative
and a headwind to um you know
multinational earnings at a time where
it's still
very very fragile um in the backdrop
and then in terms of sectors um a couple
of usual suspects i don't know that
there's anything here really
revolutionary
um the big one that's been talked about
a lot is really big tech
um likely to be under scrutiny
regardless of who wins you know the
winners
are always having the targets on their
backs right and so
at the end of the day what is the
regulatory backdrop going to look like
for mega cap tech and silicon valley
we think it's probably more noise than
news but it's definitely something we
are keeping our eye on
health care obviously in the midst of a
pandemic
but in any election cycle health care is
always in the crosshairs and so looking
at rising costs looking at drug price
reforms
expansion of uninsured coverage the list
goes on and on and so
it's a headwind regardless of who wins
the election in our view
and so continue to watching watch
healthcare very very closely and then
the energy story
another doozy and it really depends on
your point of view
as to whether it's a winner or a loser
so
very very different kind of bifurcated
outcomes depending on who wins
clearly regulations and restrictions
have come down very significantly under
the current administration
but biden supports the new the green new
deal
um he supports ending oil and gas
drilling on federal lands
he supports a recommitment to the paris
agreement on climate change and so
for our esg oriented investors our
responsible investing
clients that is a really important and
strong positive
and so it really kind of depends on your
line of sight and your point of view
as to how that may uh play out um in a
portfolio context so again positioning
and exposures definitely matter there so
i want to throw out one scenario which
is down the fairway
or kind of down the middle of the two
scenarios you just described which is
uh if we go into the election with eight
supreme court justices
uh and there is this uh kind of election
result that is called into question by
either side or even maybe both sides uh
it feels like there's this underpinning
of
that is a possibility maybe not probable
but a possibility with mail and voting
and all that kind of stuff
and we end up in a situation where
there's like a locked
uh supreme court ruling uh what
happens and obviously i don't think
that's ever occurred before so it's kind
of
we don't know is probably the answer
which is how do you think through
what would end up being probably the
most uncertain of all
potential outcomes here um and how the
market would react to something like
that
well you're right the answer is i don't
know and from a legislative and
kind of uh rules-based uh of law
kind of argument i don't have a
technical answer for you
my intuition around it would be that the
market would trade off
maybe not overnight um and maybe not
to a kind of record-breaking correction
level that
what we saw earlier in the year again
with all the stimulus sitting in the
system that is going to provide some
underlying level of support that wasn't
there
when covid kicked off but i do think
that the market will
struggle mightily with that uncertainty
at the end of the day what matters the
most is does it
impact the outcome impact the trajectory
of earnings growth
um does it impact the trajectory of
economic growth
does it impact the trajectory of
monetary policy
will all of those things suddenly
fundamentally crack
um overnight or in the you know days or
weeks following
um a lack of outcome as it relates to
the election i don't think so
um so corrections are natural this is
not a satisfying answer but
corrections are natural and healthy
normal
market functioning behavior we had a bit
of a correction coming into september
here
i think i welcomed it after the
exhaustion that was the rally
um off the bottom in in april and i
think we very well could see that
again just given where positioning is um
in in sort of the hedging and trading
kind of world and where
volatility and the fear gauge is sitting
i think it's very likely that we could
see
a correction but at the end of the day i
think it would be more of a technical
one
and short-lived as long as the
fundamental backdrop kind of stayed
intact based on where we are today
that really is what would drive a more
meaningful correction in my view if we
started to see the wheels come off
earnings growth or even q4 earnings
season which would kick off in early
january
and guidance slashed or you know cut in
a very significant way
those are the things that i would start
to worry about it's not so much the
election itself it's kind of
all these things down the line all right
we're now at the most important part of
the conversation
which is uh bitcoin um i wanna caveat
this entire part of the conversation
with uh
you manage uh by proxy a lot of money
uh about 150 billion in assets uh
maybe just talk a little bit about uh
first
what work you guys have done on bitcoin
have you looked at it what some of the
structural issues are
with if you actually did want to go get
uh exposure to it
and then we can kind of talk through
just kind of how you guys
look at an asset that is in you know the
finance markets very new
uh very different kind of just your
thought process and the work you guys
have done
uh around bitcoin specifically well i
i'm just going to kind of jump in here
and again you you guide me wherever
um you'd like to take it i don't want to
get too far into the technical weeds on
this but i'll give you my 30 000 foot
kind of stratus
strategist view we really started paying
attention
to what was happening in the crypto
world back in 2017
and then really after that massive uh
rally
in terms of pricing and the crash you
know
the the idea that it just didn't go away
right that it didn't just vaporize
itself after that
crash um from an all-time high it really
has been on the radar ever since then
trying to get an understanding of what
is going on here
and what is the potential path forward
um
i'll give you some thoughts about how we
think about it
today again from an asset allocation
standpoint and from a strategy
point of view so we think about
cryptocurrencies
as effectively a digital currency but
the challenge with that from our
perspective
is that we don't trade currencies that
is not really
an asset class in our view um it's not
that we don't
have hedged exposures to currency so a
good example of this is we
we found an active manager a third-party
strategy that invests in global
infrastructure
and part of their thesis is hedging
around
some currency exposures depending on the
country
and so it was just the right exposure
that we were looking for
and even though the hedging part of it
is really not something
that is in keeping with how we think
about the world
um we've offloaded that to them to do so
if that if they think they can add value
there or at least provide ballast in a
hedging currency
approach we're okay but with pursuing
that strategy so that's point one
the other aspect of this is if we really
wanted to
express a very nuanced view so
without a currency you know as a uh
primarily us-based investor if we
thought
a currency in a particular region or
country was going to go against us but
we really thought there was an
attractive investment opportunity there
we might think about putting a tactical
allocation in place
with a hedging component to it but in
general we are not
active currency traders and i think to
do this
right and to do this efficiently and
have any shot at adding value
you really do have to be very active in
terms of trading so that's kind of
key point one the other point of it is
if you think about cryptocurrency as
more of a store of value
then we would equate that as being more
like digital gold
and at the end of the day why would you
own gold
it's really for inflation hedging
purposes
and so at the end of the day based on
our analysis
we actually think the better inflation
hedge over longer horizons
is equities and in particular dividend
paying equity so not the high
yielders but those that have that
ability to grow dividends
over time and so it's not quite the
right
fit at the moment depending on how you
define it
in terms of our asset class universe and
so that has been
a little bit of a challenge in terms of
thinking about
how it fits into a portfolio and what
its role might actually
be um i i know you talked to kramer not
that long ago
about having well why don't you just
throw one percent
allocation into a portfolio no big deal
right one percent
but if you think about the size of our
asset base
you know we're somewhere in the neighbor
of 150 billion dollars in assets under
management so that
moves around as the market moves around
but we
effectively become bitcoin whales if we
took one percent
of that uh asset base and plunked it
into
uh crypto currencies of sorts and you
know bitcoin
i think the market cap there would
equate to somewhere in the neighborhood
of the size of a stock like at
t so it would effectively be saying
let's make an allocation to one security
let's buy one percent um in every single
client's portfolio at t even if we
thought the investment pieces made sense
and this is by the way not a knock on a
t at all this is just a hypothetical
example
it's just really too small at this stage
to try to incorporate it into a
portfolio
in an efficient way and then in a
meaningful way
one percent of anything doesn't really
move the needle
uh for better or worse and so we tend to
try to take
larger positions and portfolios whatever
exposure we're trying to to gain access
to
than just kind of one percent so that's
that's sort of how we think about that
i think the area that's really
interesting and just fascinating to me
is the technology underpinning
cryptocurrency and it's really the
blockchain technology
i think if that led to some scalable
uses
we would absolutely pursue those
opportunities from an
investment standpoint but just trading
you know like defy tokens or
day-to-day trading you know bitcoin it
that's just really
it's not an area that you know we're
playing in from an asset allocation an
investment strategy standpoint i think
longer term i'm all in on the idea
so i'm a big fan i'm watching from afar
but i'm definitely
a big fan here i think it will continue
to gain traction
again as people start to come around to
the idea of
is it a usable currency is it a store of
value what what kind of role how do we
define it
where does it sit in a portfolio context
i know traders
love it today for it's uncorrelated
asset like nature i'm all for
uncorrelated assets as well but again
there's still some
some hurdles that we need to overcome
here and then
i think too you know it's still just a
very very new world
and and new asset and i think there is
some inherent distrust
like it or not there is a little bit of
a stigma to overcome there but i think
really the blockchain technology could
be the platform of innovation
for the future not only for like this
next cycle but the next
multiple cycles and if you think about
kind of pre-covered that long
slow sluggish cycle that we've been
through the last 11 plus years
there's been an innovation drought there
have been pockets of innovation but it
really hasn't been
grand and sweeping enough to drive
meaningful
productivity enhancements and gdp growth
and so
i think the prospects for this are just
really really
interesting so much potential here but
it's still
very very early days so we're going to
keep watching it very closely and
you know maybe i can come back on the
show and talk to you about when and
how we start to implement it in
portfolios
so uh one i think that everything uh
you just said is really really rational
right and i think that uh there's this
thought process
in uh the bitcoin slash crypto community
of
uh everyone's asleep at the wheel no
one's paying attention like
you know the the large asset management
firms are completely missing this and
uh just given the uh you know thoughts
you've shared here
uh obviously you guys have one been
paying attention
for multiple years to have a pretty good
understanding of the various narratives
around the asset
uh and then three even have gone as far
as like well even if we could get there
as to yes this asset
makes sense for whatever reason like
could we do it right
from an execution standpoint and
i think every single thing you outline
um not only is one rational but makes
sense and as challenges you guys face
my favorite question to ask people
though is what would change your mind
or what what are the things that you're
going to look for in the future in terms
of saying
you know what now maybe the time where
we think this becomes more interesting
is it
price related is it structure and like
regulation related
is it macro economy something shifts and
then
something like this becomes more
interesting but just how do you think
through
kind of maybe things you'll watch
as this unfolds um and really the
thought process is for those people that
are listening
uh you know they're probably more
insular looking like they're looking at
bitcoin
not necessarily looking at here's the
things that major asset management firms
or
or asset allocators are looking at as
kind of um
you know warning signs or alarm bells or
whatever in terms of
uh bringing more attention to it
yeah i think it's just a few short
things really that i'm looking for but
maybe
maybe it's asking way too much i mean i
think structure
is definitely important and
kind of getting an understanding of
maybe perhaps which
cryptocurrency is going to win out
there's so many different ones
um seeing a little bit of consolidation
there just like a better understanding
of what the landscape or the competitive
landscape is going to look like so i
think
i think structure is important um i
think
time just helps right this has only
really been on the scene for maybe 10 or
11 years
that maybe and so i think that you know
time and education and hand-holding
albeit virtual i think would definitely
help
a better understanding of use cases um
is also critical so if i think about you
know the us
today what are those use cases you know
it makes a ton of sense
in other countries where perhaps there's
a lot more distrust around
government power political power
regulatory oversight etc
totally get that and let me just say the
crisis of confidence that we
experienced at the beginning of this
year from
you know government policy officials
public health policy officials
even you know the fed i mean there was
so much mixed messaging going on like
who's in charge
and you know what is the path forward
going to look like and who makes the
final decision i mean i totally get it
that's maybe kind of a a weak example
but i
understand sort of the inherent distrust
and wanting to kind of step away from
you know the us dollar perhaps other
kind of global currencies and so
um i don't think that we're necessarily
expecting to see
greater regulation in this area would be
kind of at odds
right a little bit with uh the whole
idea
um of cryptocurrencies so that's not
necessarily it i think it's more on the
structure
of the industry side consolidation use
cases
um and then really vehicles to implement
more on the innovation side right not
not just trading
the currencies themselves but you know
is there a venture capital fund or are
there multiple venture capital funds or
private investment type of vehicles that
are capturing
early stage um blockchain oriented
technologies
investments innovations that kind of
thing i think there's a huge
opportunity there there's just not a lot
to choose from
today and so again i think it comes back
to it's just still a little bit early
we need to see a little bit more growth
and expansion of
of the use cases and the opportunities
there and then i think asset managers
will start to come around
i think that is a very fair view of the
world uh and i do not envy
you having the conversation internally
about hey do you guys want to look at
this bitcoin thing
because i can only imagine the the
various reactions that you get
internally
there are a lot of different reactions
it's the wide spectrum
of uh emotions and opinions and feelings
about it
absolutely but that's the reason why
we're having the conversation
right if we were all thinking along the
exact same lines
something's wrong and so it is
definitely a lively
um and very recurring debate that
continues and we'll and we'll continue
i i don't know who they are but it
sounds like there's bitcoiners who have
infiltrated the uh the office so we'll
uh we'll see how it plays out
uh before we get into the rapid fire
questions to wrap up uh where can people
find you on the internet or find out
more
uh with the work that you guys are
pushing in terms of the market outlooks
and just the content that you guys
continue to produce
well there are a number of things that
show up uh
on pnc.com so that is a good starting
point certainly for a number of the
formal publications that we put out you
can also find me on twitter
my handle is amanda agati pnc and so i
try my best to
share as many publications as i can for
that
channel and also the insanity that is my
mind and reaction to
you know whatever the news of the day
might be you might also find a panda
video or two
it's a little bit of a mishmash of
everything but
that's also um a good way to kind of
track what
our views of the world are and what's
really top of mind for me
and the investment strategy team on any
given day
panda videos are welcome no no uh no
qualms there at all
right of course um i asked the same two
questions everybody to wrap up and then
you'll get to ask me one the first
is what is the most important book that
you've ever read
oh that is a good one um i would say the
most important book
well there are probably two but if i had
to pick one i would go
with andy lowe's adaptive markets
which is actually a more recent read
it's not from
uh you know eons ago and um
i think what resonates the most uh with
me about that
is this really inherently dynamic
complex adaptive system that is the
markets
it's a really an organism that's kind of
living and breathing and continuously
learning
and continuously improving and so
that's really something that i have
taken away and tried to apply in the
context of
investment strategy and how we think
about the shorter term as well as the
longer term
that continuous improvement dynamic be
nimble
you may have made decisions about things
like cryptocurrency
in the past but things evolve and in
fairly dramatic fashion
especially given you know all the issues
that are swirling around in the macro
backdrop and so
you got to try and get out ahead of it
because the market is going to
continually adapt
and think about things in a very complex
sort of way
and so it also injects a little bit of
psychology
behavioral finance into the equation as
well and i thought it was a really
impactful book that i
highly recommend that's an awesome
suggestion no one's recommended that one
uh second question is more fun aliens
are you a believer
or a non-believer oh
that is a good question no one has ever
asked me that before
uh i'm gonna say i'm a believer
sure why not why should why should there
only be
life existing on this earth
um the universe is uh you know
totally expansive right unending surely
there has to be other life forms
in some way shape or form out there so
in a former life i wanted to be an
astronomer so that's actually kind of an
interesting segue
if i wasn't a strategist i'd be an
astronomer i don't i don't know why
some may say those two things are quite
similar
they i guess maybe they are a little bit
i don't know if i
kind of intentionally thought of it that
way but you're
really pulling on my astronomer and
studying of the stars in the universe
and meaning of existence kind of uh vibe
so
i'm gonna say yes absolutely life exists
out there
i agree with you i think there's
somewhere i don't know if we're gonna
find them or if they're gonna find us
but uh but they're there somewhere
it's gonna take a while maybe that
blockchain technology
you could ask me one question to wrap up
what do you have for me
oh that is a good one um let's see
did i i guess my question to you would
be have i
demystified anything or shared anything
with you
that you might have kind of
thought a stigma about or felt
differently about
that made you stop and kind of think
twice about
i think one of the misconceptions uh
especially given the seat that you sit
in is
um this one size fits all
right and it's just like oh let's go you
know 60 40 yes no
right or uh what about public versus
private or
is there a passive bubble or whatever
and these questions get asked in
um a way of and i'm as guilty as anybody
because they're fun to debate
right in terms of uh just everyone wants
an
answer like what is the answer and i
think what
you really highlighted earlier and is a
challenge of
your job is like you're serving
different customers so that big
foundation or that big institution
has very different goals very different
objectives very different
resources right has different time
horizons than maybe an individual who
you know has kind of saved some money
and is trying to grow their wealth
uh but doesn't have the same kind of
infrastructure things that maybe an
institution has
and so to me it's one of these things
where it's hard enough to manage a
portfolio when you just have one set of
goals and objectives
and kind of have to think through what
are the resources i have what's my time
horizon
when you then multiply that across you
know all the way from a large
institution to a single individual like
uh i do not envy the uh the kind of uh
duplicatous nature of having do that
over and over and over again but come to
a different conclusion each time
because i think it kind of challenges uh
maybe the beliefs that you hold
right and you've got to be able to
context switch which
um i don't think people have an
appreciation for that
like most people struggle to manage
their own portfolio well what if you had
to do you know
10 different types of clients portfolio
and so i think that just you know really
comes through
as an added challenge to what is already
a pretty difficult job of just managing
a portfolio
that's great well i'm glad that helped
clarify a little bit on that front can i
ask you one other question
of course what's your spirit animal ooh
spirit animal um
man just like 10 animals went through my
head i don't know if that's good or bad
um i kind of think that like something
like a
cockroach or something like that uh
mainly just because it's like uh
whether when you're building a business
when you're doing kind of uh content
stuff even when you're investing in
businesses
like the first goal is just don't die
right like if you just survive like
there's got to be some value that
accrues um
and so if you think of just like all the
animals in the world that maybe aren't
deemed
uh tough or uh very predatory
but still somehow like they just never
go away um i tend to think that like
that's a pretty good
strategy in life of like you know it's
kind of like investing right like just
don't lose all the money like rule
number one and so uh
if you could stay in the game for a long
period of time you got a shot at at
least growing it somehow
no what's yours i'm going panda
oh that's why hence the panda videos
when i think about
a panda um it's a little bit like i'm a
female
in a largely male dominated industry
pandas are somewhat rare right if it not
endangered
in the wild so there's a little bit of a
connection there and then
um i would also kind of say it's a
little bit of a
poke the bear or don't poke the bear
kind of thing i can be
very warm and fuzzy and cuddly but at
the same time like
don't poke the bear
so that that's kind of what resonated
and then of course
you get the usual amanda panda thing
growing up so yeah that's an awesome
answer i think that's what resonates
most uh with me
i love that all right amanda listen
thank you so much for doing this i think
people are really really gonna enjoy
this one
and uh when you end up actually getting
allocation to bitcoin even if it's 20
years from now we're going to come back
we're going to do this
so thanks so much for doing it we'll do
it again in the future awesome it was so
great chatting with you thank you so
much